hi everyone Sal Khan here for our daily
homeroom for those of y'all who are new
to this Khan Academy we are
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and when we saw the
math school closures not just in the
United States but around the world
there's now over 1.4 billion students
around the world who normally would go
to school who aren't we realized that
above and beyond the resources that Khan
Academy has been creating for years and
offering for free for teachers students
and parents for students inside of
platforms and outside of classrooms
around the world that it's our duty to
step up and do more so we've been doing
things like parent and teacher webinars
we've been publishing things like the
daily schedules for different age groups
that some of y'all might be familiar
with and we are also doing this live
stream and it's a it's a way to stay
connected in this time of social
distancing it's a way to answer any
questions that you might have and it's
also a way to have interesting
conversations that are related to what's
going on around us it could be related
to education or it could be related to
just the broader environment I do want
to say a few thank-yous as I mentioned
we're not-for-profit were funded with
philanthropic donations even before the
kovat crisis we were running at a
deficit and now our our traffic on Khan
Academy is is about two and a half it
looks like I'd look this morning it's
about 2.8 what it normally is and so
that only increases our cost so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about helping us out kind of kind
of me an out org slash donate and I want
to give a special thanks to several
corporations who stepped up over the
last couple of weeks in record time to
help us with this Cove in response these
include folks like Bank of America which
was the first to step up and shortly
thereafter eighty google.org and
Novartis and that's above and beyond
many of the foundations and
philanthropists and corporations like
Amgen that have a funded Khan Academy
through the years and as much as that
funding helps I do want to emphasize
that we still need more we're still
operating in a significant
deficit so funding at any level helps
over the weekend I put a video out on
YouTube essentially just doing whatever
I just did
saying that one video and before we help
raise us a lot of money so thank you for
doing that at least spread the word I
also want to emphasize that we are still
running at a deficit and depleting our
reserves in order to to do what we're
doing so what we're going to do today
like always whether you're watching this
on YouTube Facebook or some other social
media channel this is changing day by
day the we're getting fancier every day
but start posting questions I have
access to some of them and then some of
our team members are looking at those
questions and they're putting it up on a
doc that I can read but we have a
special guest today our special guest
today is a teacher by the name of Tim
Vandenberg who teaches sixth grade
students in Hesperian California and I
think there's a couple of really
interesting or many interesting things
to talk to Tim about but when you think
about the questions you can ask
questions for me but also you can post
questions whether you're a teacher
parent or student from a really
impressive teacher that'll help us think
about how connected we can be used in
the classroom or for maximum impact but
also maybe some ways to think about
views at home during the closures so Tim
thanks thanks for joining us I stopped
and actually I was watching this
documentary about Monopoly recently and
beyond being us where our teacher you
were also what was it number two in the
country in monopoly at the last US
Championships I play second place so
they say that put me is ranked number
two in country so there's a lot of fun
you're such a soccer gym oh ok so we
might have a few champions in that group
do so so maybe a good place to start you
know tell us tell everybody how you've
you know pre kovat crisis how you were
using Khan Academy in your classroom the
the students that you've been trying to
help out where were they before and then
what what have you seen since well
with Khan Academy and so what I decided
it is I'm gonna make my 6th graders go
back to the early gray levels do early
math arithmetic the lower grade levels
on Khan Academy to master and fill in
the holes like you've described so well
in your many videos that I encourage
people to go watch and by having them go
back and review and fill in those gaps
these very low disadvantaged highly
diverse kids who were basically failing
their lower grade skills on the state
test for California they ended up
absolutely doing fantastic on their
state tests results over the last three
years and it would have been four years
in a row but California decided not to
have state testing this year due to the
emergency health situation but we have a
a data chart I can show the absolutely
amazing results using mastery learning I
think your team is going to post that up
so on the left hand side you can see on
how these kids did in fifth grade
compared to their California County and
district peers and this is compared to
the Green Line on top that is a passing
score in fifth grade over to a passing
score in sixth grade on the right and
you see my kids basically the average
kid in California and the county and
district and my class are very far below
grade level but using the mastery
learning model that is so powerful and
easy to do on Khan Academy my kids
average growing 95 points last year and
pretty much sustained the last two years
before that as well compare that to the
average kid in California went up just
over one point one point of growth
that's the best scores I can find over
the last three years in California was
two years ago
that's almost 95 times the growth of the
average kid
that doesn't mean every description Nazi
huh and just which I understand this
chart what this shows is on the left
hand side the left point is performance
on the fifth grade state test and then
on the right date of dot a Foreman's a
sixth grade so a student who just just
tracks that green line on black that
means they're right at grade level for
fifth grade and then a year later
they're right at sixth grade for sixth
grade so that would be what essentially
the standards or the assessments expect
of students essentially you get a year
of learning in the year and it looks
like California on average starts fifth
grade well below grade level and and
then start sixth grade well below great
ork starts the year well below grade
level and then NZ you're up above grade
level but there's about a great level of
growth but your students yeah and I
think if I read some of your the
background 90% of them were below grade
level and what you're looking at we're
looking at is the average but
significantly below grade level you're
talking you know a high needs student
body 100% free and reduced lunch but
over the course of the year them almost
all of them being significantly below
grade level to almost all of them being
significantly above grade level after a
year exactly and and this is for
teachers might understand as parents may
not quite grasp this but this is
absolutely amazing growth and this is
real and this is not teaching to the
test this is lives change these kids now
believe that they can learn math and
master math all things to mastery
learning model on Khan Academy because
they actually I want to make sure
explain that explain how those gaps are
actually filled in what's interesting is
these are sixth grade students and
you're starting them off many times at
early learning which is kindergarten
first second grade or arithmetic type
content and many both could say wait if
they're gonna go all the way back there
okay ever get to grade level content
let's get ahead of rate level right so
during the school year why while still
simultaneously teaching and
mastering the great skills which is very
hard for them because they don't have
the foundations we also require them to
go back and do the course challenges and
the unit tests for all of the lower
grade levels so that that math actually
start to make sense to them so that they
truly become math masters and champions
and actually stopping that this is
something they can do and the majority
of them I graduate and send them off to
honors class or above level classes in
junior high because of this and this is
really a bit of an idea as you can see
even going slow to go fast you know we
talked a lot about it your Khan Academy
that in a traditional model let's say a
student gets an 80% on you know their
multiplication tables then the next year
when they're learning division and
they're building it on a weak foundation
and multiplication or when you get to
algebra and there's a decimal if you
only got 70% in fifth grade decimals and
I'm building on a weak foundation and
that might be or that arguably is the
reason why so many people struggle in
math and see the data gets worse and
worse the farther you get a advance
because those gaps come debilitating but
when you've been able to do is use Khan
Academy to allow kids to start early if
they know the material in kindergarten
which most of no but some of them might
even have a gap or two they can fill
those in and then by the time they get
to that sticks fade material now they're
ready to move ahead and you do both of
those simultaneously exactly and if this
is life changing I encourage every
parent at home with their child at home
having remote learning every teacher it
may be at least up for this as extra
credit or something for the rest of the
school year to go back and do those
mastery challenges quickly go through
those course challenges quickly go
through lower grades and if it takes
them a long time good they needed to do
that review if they do it quickly okay
good now we know what they know and can
zero in on which particular skills they
were struggling with but we all know by
high school kids think either they
understand now because he really got it
or they think math is just member
rising steps because they really have no
clue what's going on and they've
actually quit math because they think
they just don't have a math brain well
Khan Academy can fix that and teach and
show that every kid can learn master
math thanks to growth mindset especially
and I want to talk a little about school
closures and here's what we're doing but
staying on the classroom model which I
know there's a lot of teachers listening
and I'm sure many students and parents
would be curious about this as well you
know when I look at these videos of your
classmate they look highly interactive
they're sometimes the steered that when
you use technology your blended learning
it can be this you know Vulcan or Borg
reality where it's just kids on
computers what is what do you see is
your role if the students are practicing
on mine Academy they're getting a
feedback acting a little micro lesson
when they need it what do you see is the
role of the teacher in the room right
the role of the teacher or the parent
they're doing this at home with their
child is to be actively engaged
monitoring progress helping the kids at
point of need but after they have first
used the Khan videos and the Khan hits
or their classmates or at home their
older siblings or their parents and the
teachers role is to jump in and help us
needed but first I teach them about
agency and initiative and take ownership
for their own learning but there is the
coach the support is needed but you see
these kids this is normal what you see
in the videos there they truly learn to
learn mostly on their own but they know
when they need me I'm right there and
that's a par 5 year because obviously
you and I we both like mathematics we
both think it's valuable to learn that
but would you mention that notion of
agency that might be the most important
thing of all because then they're off to
the races you you've taught them to to
fish so to speak it's one way to think
about it what it what is how are you
dealing you know what's this I'm
assuming your school has been closed in
Experian for several weeks I am curious
we haven't talked about this
what are you what's going on in your
district how are you dealing with the
school years right you know our school
helps our entire district
clothes like I believe all schools in
California well it worked out
beautifully the transition my students
took their Chromebooks home and they
just keep going
they just keep leveling up their skill
mastery where they were on each of those
courses and we're gonna be setting up
remote learning real soon here now the
kids are back from Spring Break so I
gave a must week off but we're gonna be
doing remote learning but they're
basically on Khan Academy and I had kids
yesterday without even asking half the
class going on Khan Academy without even
being asked to and leveling up skills
and mastering new things even without me
helping them but wait do you need help
absolutely on their example so the model
that you it sounds like you're doing is
you already had kids working on Khan
Academy before the closures and then the
closures happen it was pretty easy
obviously to transition in some level
goes I guess device is is is an issue
especially I could imagine for a student
with hundred percent free and reduced
lunch but it sounds like y'all had a
great program to send the Chromebooks
home I am curious about internet access
but what you're saying is the kids are
able to access it keep working and it
sounds like might also be supplementing
that with um you know videoconferencing
to unblock them if necessary
exactly and yeah we do have most kids
with Wi-Fi with internet access and the
ones you know then I supplement through
other paper/pencil sort of materials
technics and stuff but the vast majority
of the kids can get online because that
was the expectation at the start here
and and those who couldn't well I just
found flexible ways to help those who
need help and I am curious given that it
sounds like your kids are continuing to
learn well how are you thinking about
the length of the school closures it
looks like it could very well go through
the end of the whole year I do what
advice do you for other teachers parents
for students of using this time as well
as possible but then also the summer
time absolutely what a beautiful
opportunity to use Khan Academy we're
just
and I'm not going to say that every why
not use this time at home catching up on
all those skills go back to kindergarten
do the course challenge on kindergarten
see if you can finish it master it all
in an hour - if not then you probably
needed to review some skills even
starting in third grade there are some
very difficult skills that a lot of high
schoolers never mastered because they
were not on common core way back then
use this time to go back and review
skills fill in those gaps and make my
mix that's for you so you can be a math
chant
while you're home doing River learning
and teachers and parents
I recommend somehow motivating your kids
your students your children to use this
master learning model this is absolutely
life-changing I've seen it three years
in a row now four years after this
school year these kids lives are
absolutely changed they believe they can
learn and master math instead of being a
failure at math like 90% of them were at
lower grade they're no playing junior in
high school right now my alumni and they
are destroying their math classes doing
fantastic destroying in a good way
little empirical way just like that now
we don't work in a good way I had an
internal giggle honey when you said that
we're not paying you because obviously
it's not for profit we will love it when
people use us but our costs actually go
up which is why I'm always asking folks
for money but no we don't pay you and
and no no it's great this is why we
exist and the you know I've only met you
I think we had our first conversation
only a few weeks ago but I've been
really a blow but you know I've spoken
and I've written about a lot of these
things in theory but you've taken it to
a whole other level in terms of practice
so I think it's a good time we can open
it up to some questions I see there's
questions coming in so one question from
YouTube Susanna Dominguez asked our mr.
V students continuing to work on Khan at
home now that we are homebound it sounds
like that is the case in fact it sounds
you can't even stop them even what they
were all yeah what I do is like I praise
them for those who everyday I use the
Khan Activity overview
data that conne provides for teachers
and parents and I praise the top ten
kids who put in the most effort and also
the top ten kids who've leveled up the
most skills from the previous day and
that really motivates them that positive
reinforcement awesome and have this
other question from Facebook Missy
mullet says Tim have you had students
that master all K through fifth skills
before the year is up do you have them
move ahead of class into later sixth or
seventh grade topics right as a sixth
grade teacher every year I do have two
or three kids who master everything K
through six
so what I do is I unlock I call it
unlock but I let them go ahead to
pre-algebra and seventh grade and eighth
grade math and I let that for that
credit in a balanced way you know I'm
getting a plus bus and a junior high
basically ready to teach their seventh
grade class and probably should push
they had to equity math right away
that's incredible
and let's see from Facebook Niki Renee
asked if I set up second grade math my
child does all the practice quizzes and
unit tests where do you go from there do
you have to achieve something before it
automatically moves you on I can take a
quick stab at that one essentially yes
once your student get through say nine
percent mastery in second grade math
through unit tests or course challenges
on mastery challenges then it would be a
good idea that's it you know this is a
younger student you're talking about do
then say okay it looks like you've
finished second grade and then you can
set them a goal to finish third grade
and you can even pace that out the
things we want to work on Khan Academy
we gave you all the daily schedules for
different age groups but just as Tim was
mentioning we have two months through
the school year then we have another
three months through the summer we want
to help parents and students and
teachers think about goals that are
reasonable for different types of
students as we go over the next five
months but you're at I'll finish the
second grade absolutely the system right
now I won't say immediately go to third
grade but you can sit next to them and
say okay let's start on there great now
all right so
Facebook Kati Kelly de la DeLeon says hi
10 I have hard time navigating the
website how do you assign the mastery
model that you teach to your students
okay so as a teacher you want to make
sure your students are signed in under
your class in Khan Academy and they go
under each course and you can set
mastery goals for your students and you
can even set a date deadline for your
students and what that does is it
signals to your kids that this is what
they should be working on and then it
keeps track and you can then click on
that as a teacher and follow the
progress as their percentage of mastery
goes up so I hope that answers Katy's
question and that's good feedback for
all of us actually both of y'all good
feedback Katie we are always trying to
improve the navigation so we actually
like the constructive feedback we know
it can get it can get better
and Tim's idea I actually think I would
love to collaborate with you Tim of ways
to kind of publish goals over the course
of especially the next five months and I
would love to do it consistent the way
you've done it because clearly it's been
highly effective and I think that'll
help a lot of parents students and
teachers so someone from you to see
YouTube da lad said I don't understand
how students take tests on kinda I've
only seen videos so doll I I think you
might only be on the YouTube channel I
encourage you to go to Khan Academy org
and if you go to you know you can
there's a menu that says subjects at the
top left if you go there especially if
you look at any of the ones in math or
the high school level Sciences including
biology chemistry physics econ APCs
principles you will see there's a view
where you have videos on the left and on
the right you have practice and if you
click on that you'll see that as you get
things right it has these what we call
mastery mechanics that'll show you so
you can see right here on the on the on
the this is showing the various lessons
but you can see these mastery points
available and then if you were to click
on one of those lessons then you'll be
able to see the the the
various exercises you can do and get
feedback and there's different levels
you could do it at the skill level you
can do it at a at a quiz level unit test
level of mastery challenge level or a
course challenge so I encourage you to
go to our site and try it all out
all right so other questions so some of
these are a little bit more general
so from YouTube Michael Azhar says Sal
is there any way I can improve my skills
using Khan Academy efficiently so I have
some ideas and actually I'm curious Tim
what you think about this so I think the
best way to efficiently use Khan Academy
is analogous to what you just heard Tim
say that he coaches his students to do
is start at a level that's maybe earlier
than your grade level unless you're very
very confident in math but if you're not
started in earlier grade level and I
would start with the course challenges
because that samples everything in the
class and if you're able to get through
the course challenges quite easily you
can move on to the next grade level but
if you're not able to move through the
course challenges easily the things that
you got wrong you can then go to those
units and then try to get mastery in
those units and I would say that's the
most efficient way to get mastery at
some of your foundational subjects as as
quickly as possible there's also ways
you know if you're gonna learn anything
whether it's math or piano or improve
your free-throw it's all about
consistency a lot of times we're all
guilty of binge you know studying or or
binge exercising then we do nothing for
a few weeks it's much better if you can
do a solid 30 minutes a day 40 minutes a
day if you're younger maybe 20 minutes a
day you're going to see that if you do
that consistently that's going that
you're gonna notice you you you
performing better you're looking at the
world differently in a matter of a month
or two
Tim anything at anything to add to that
yeah I can't tell you how powerful it is
to use the early math course to focus on
mastering the number sense concepts
which is usually research has shown is
what holds kids and even adults back is
grasping the true meaning of numbers and
place value in fractions so early math
and then the arithmetic course on Khan
Academy is a good summary review of
every
basically K through maybe seventh grade
that those are great
turbo super fast reviews to get through
everything and make sure you truly
understand what you need for junior high
in high school then for older students
the pre-algebra course really teaches
those basic skills of working the key
concepts of algebraic manipulation and
one thing I'll add you know both Tim and
I have been talking a lot about this
importance of really strong foundations
but I've seen a lot of parents have a
little bit of anxiety when it comes to
math and I think this is also an
opportunity now that we're all socially
distance at home that if you do have
some time and maybe even do it next year
a child it's really great modeling for
them for you to do what Tim has just
mentioned to go back to early learning
if you know that material you'll get
through it quite fast and if it takes
you a little bit more time it's because
you needed it and I think that'll change
your perspective and it's very powerful
modeling for the students yeah I have
had a couple of parents do that with
their children and not only does it help
the parent it encourages it's the Kami
this year with scare depressions you
never know my mom has been working
together with her on her own account con
and them together amazing state practice
tests that we have been taking so it's
been great parents motivate your kids
that's awesome there's a question from
Facebook
Edward Swanson are there plans to match
up content with the UK system so Edward
right now we don't have that in theory
that could happen in the future so so
it's definitely the realm of possibility
I would stay that obviously the UK
system is - even in the u.s. state state
can be a little bit different it is
different but especially in math if you
master the progression along the lines
that tim has been talking about make
sure you have a strong foundation you
can go to pretty much any country and
there might be a few standards that are
different there you will have a very
strong foundation and you'll feel
yourself very fluent in math and the
same thing is also true for things like
biology chemistry physics if you're
thinking about things more at a high
school
or early college level so I encourage
you to do that it but it is a good nudge
for us to think about mapping to things
like the UK system for other
international folks out there we do have
a Spanish version of Khan Academy
use Khan Academy network there is
actually a Brazilian Portuguese version
of Khan Academy which that team in
Brazil is actually mapping to the
Brazilian national common core we have a
team in India that is trying to do
similar things
there's also 40 translation projects
around the world done by volunteers on
top of our platform to make on academy
available in those other languages and
there we remake the tools available
where they can curate and align them
better to their standard so we
definitely do want things like that to
happen and so let's the other let's see
from YouTube vaishnav Mallya I guess
there's a 10 million hello Sal Khan
Academy saved me so much frustration so
much clarity and teaching method well
thank you
vaishnav we appreciate that and then
next question I have is Lisa nice from
Facebook is saying her sixth graders
doing well in math that's that's great I
think being able to use Khan Academy we
pureeing that that makes you know it
energizes all of us to hear is about how
it's helping folks and let's see other
questions so actually this is an
interesting one and it may be both Tim
and I answered this question for YouTube
cards pop says hey Sal what is the best
piece of constructive criticism you
received from a parent or a learner so I
think the you know all that we got a
little bit of constructive kristin which
I really appreciate a little ardor to go
where I think it was a parent or a
teacher is asking hey I'm having a
little bit difficulty navigating the
site I think that is one that I've heard
a few times you know in the early days
of Khan Academy and it was in many ways
easier to navigate but now that there's
thousands of exercises and a thousands
of videos and and you know pretty 40
subjects it can be a little bit daunting
to understand how to navigate and
especially because there's different
modalities teachers can assign unit
mastery course mastery they can they can
assign individual skills for homework
so we recognize that we want to be able
to simplify it as much as possible
that's really a constructive feedback I
really early days of Khan Academy my
penmanship was not so good I got some
detective feedback about that and for
sure you know we get positive feedback
and some people like the style that I
might instruct it some people might
think I talk too slow or too fast or or
whatever else so you know it's always
great to get feedback and think about
how we can get better at things Tim what
you need constructive feedback you like
highlight yeah the the high-stakes
constructive feedback that every teacher
gets every year is their state test
student results and it was very powerful
before I use Khan Academy justing wow
it's not working using the old system I
just can't get these kids caught up in
one year even though I'm working so hard
I got it is something different so I
tried this mastery learning model and
that was the best constructive feedback
I ever got was realizing I got to change
I got to do something different and kids
ever since in my class have been having
their lives changed so that helped a lot
also I want to I think your team is
gonna post on this the show notes for
this webinar a couple of webinars
recently did explaining how to do
mastery learning the classroom or with
your child at home so be sure to check
that as well yeah no that's great and
actually one of those webinar videos I
I've now included as a link whenever I
sent an email folks just so people see
that because you know it's one thing to
theoretically know about it but to hear
from an incredible tactician or like
yourself and the type of results are
seeing with a high e population it's
really inspiring so we are all out of
time these last dreams go fast Tim thank
you so much for joining us I get
inspired every time I chat and you know
for everyone out there listening oh no
no and maybe we'll play some Monopoly
I'm finding that that might be some
constructive criticism for me you know
when you crush meat monopoly but
but for all of all of you all who are
listening thanks for joining I know this
is a really really hard time for the
world but I think that's a little bit of
a silver lining that we're all through
this together and as I'm saying every
week you know this is a way to connect
with each other I also find a lot of
connection even though it's virtual and
abstract through this livestream but
it's a way to get us through all of
these school closures I'll throw in
another reminder we are not-for-profit
if you're in a position to do so please
think about donating to Khan Academy we
need your help we're operating at a
deficit right now but I look forward to
seeing you all in the weeks ahead we're
gonna bring more guests folks like Tim
and others soon so with that stay safe
stay healthy and I'll see you tomorrow
you